ma famille politique on a voté hier une
motion à la quasi unanimité disons que
nous souhaitions voter cette réforme
pourquoi parce qu'elle est nécessaire si
on veut sauver le système qui a mis en
place le général de Gaulle celui de la
retraite par répartition si on veut pas
de même baisser les retraites il faut le
dire il y a 18 millions de retraités
aujourd'hui si demain ils ne veulent pas
voir leur retraite s'effondrer ce qui
serait une injustice parce qu'ils ont
cotisé travaillé toute leur vie il faut
demander un effort un peu supérieur
c'est-à-dire
pourquoi on fait cette retraite il y a
un problème démographique moins d'actifs
je dis pas que c'est pas intéressant
c'est ce que vous dites ce matin c'est
officiel c'est trancher c'est réglé
c'est la position du Parti les
républicains le vote c'est oui nous
l'avons dit hier mais nous avons encore
un débat parlementaire ou nous allons
essayer améliorer le texte ce texte nous
l'avions dit au début il avait un
caractère trop brutal trop rapide nous
l'avons amélioré sur les petites
retraites nous l'avons amélioré sur les
carrières longues et ce qui a annoncé la
première ministre hier est une étape
supplémentaire il reste des fois encore
plus loin il reste des points nous
allons améliorer notamment au Sénat pour
les familles pour les maires de famille
qui ne doivent pas être pénalisés et qui
doivent être au contraire mieux
accompagner dans la réforme il faut une
grande politique familiale aussi
aujourd'hui on a 100 000 naissances de
moins qu'en 2012 pendant 10 ans pourquoi
parce que Monsieur Hollande et Monsieur
Macron par la suite ont mis à mal la
grande politique familiale qui avait été
installée au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale par le général de Gaulle
toujours le général de Gaulle c'est
notre famille
politique je crois que tout ce qui a été
fait de mieux dans le pays le système
dans lequel on vit aujourd'hui ce sont
ces bases du Conseil national la
résistance il faut les poursuivre vous
avez avec une grande politique de la
famille de la natalité c'est vrai vous
avez